KORY JEFFREY: Greetings
everyone and welcome
to on-site of Founder
World in San Francisco.
I'm joined in studio by
Shanea King-Roberson,
a fellow Googler,
a program manager
and the curriculum director
of the Tech Entrepreneur
Nanodegree.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yes.
KORY JEFFREY: Yes, welcome.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
Thank you--
KORY JEFFREY: Welcome.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
--for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah, no problem.
So tell me a little
bit about yourself.
What did you do before Google?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
Prior to Google,
I started a digital marketing
agency with a business partner.
We exclusively helped women
authors, entrepreneurs,
and speakers develop
online presence
and create social
media strategies.
We also executed for them.
It's been really an
amazing experience
being able to help entrepreneurs
really craft their message
and really get it out there for
the world to be able to hear.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's really cool.
Did you do it in the
San Francisco area?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
No, I actually
did it in the San
Diego area, and then I
moved around a little bit.
However, what makes internet
and tech businesses so great,
you can be remote from anywhere
and still run your business.
KORY JEFFREY: How did you
transition from that to Google?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
We were growing.
We still have clients.
If a old client calls, I'm
still definitely there for them.
But an opportunity came
up to be a part of Google.
And Google calls,
so you kind of go.
KORY JEFFREY: How did you
end up within Nanodegree?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
Well, I was actually
part of the developer
relations release team.
When we decided to
do a restructuring,
they asked me what I was
really passionate about,
and I ended up being on the
Google Developer Training Team.
It just so happens that they
needed a program manager
for the Tech
Entrepreneurship Nanodegree.
And I told the lead,
Peter, about it
and my experience
with my own company,
and my passion for helping
get businesses started.
And he goes, I think
you'll be perfect.
And it's gone on from there.
KORY JEFFREY: Tell me about the
Tech Entrepreneur Nanodegree.
What does that entail?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah.
So a Nanodegree, just to
give everyone context,
is a collection of courses.
And Google has partnered with
the online learning platform
Udacity to provide a
collection of courses.
And the Nanodegree itself is
all project-based, interactive
learning experience where you
have two to three minute videos
followed by immediately
an assessment,
so that you're
constantly engaged
and constantly learning.
And then at the end of each
course, you do a project,
and then you do a
final capstone project.
However, all of
the courses and all
of the content that
make up the Nanodegree
is available for free.
So the additional services
that Udacity provides,
which is one-on-one
coaching, job placement
services, a community, that
aspect has an additional fee.
But from Google,
we want everyone
to be able to
experience our content.
KORY JEFFREY: And is this
Google created content?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah.
We did it in
partnership with Google
so you'll be able to see not
only a lot of Google faces,
such as the program manager
of Google's Launchpad program,
you'll also be able to see a
lot of developer advocates,
myself, my face.
But you also get a chance to
meet other amazing minds that
are in the Silicon Valley area.
Like we've partnered with
the startup company Envision
to produce rapid prototyping.
We've also done a
bunch of interviews,
such as the CEO of Optimizely.
We've worked with Aaron
Harris from Y Combinator.
We've interviewed
venture capitalists.
Nir Eyal of the book
"Hooked-- How to Build
Habit-Forming Products."
Amazing.
Geoffrey Moore from
"Crossing the Chasm,"
we've interviewed him, and
it's absolutely amazing.
So it's not just Google,
but brilliant minds
from all over the tech industry
are able to give entrepreneurs
the knowledge that they need to
really start their businesses.
KORY JEFFREY: So if we
dive into the content,
it sounds like a little
bit of rapid prototyping,
obviously some marketing with
Geoffrey Moore, some finance
stuff.
Are there other pillars
that this degree covers?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah.
So we actually start
off with product design.
And product designing goes
back even further than that
by starting off with ideation.
So even if you haven't
solidified your idea yet,
we actually teach you how
to come up with an idea
and validate it in the market
before you ever build anything
so that you're not
wasting your time.
So we start off with that.
How to build products,
accessible products,
for markets, global markets,
how to design your products
for local markets as
you expand globally.
Then we go into monetization.
So you actually build
a monetization strategy
before you build a prototype
because your UI is affected
by how you decide to monetize.
And what happens to a
lot of entrepreneurs
is they build this
amazing product
and then have to go back
and change their interface
to add ads or new payment
buttons or anything like that.
We want entrepreneurs to start
thinking about those things
before they ever build
anything so that they are not
wasting valuable time
or valuable dollars.
KORY JEFFREY: All right.
So looking at the roadmap for
the program, it exists today.
Where is it available?
How do you sign up?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah.
The current roadmap is
product design, monetization,
rapid prototyping, then
marketing, and then
how to get your startup started,
which is all the businessy,
finance stuff.
All of those courses
are available
at Udacity.com/Google.
You'll see, when
you go to that page,
you just scroll down to the
Tech Entrepreneur section.
You'll be able to see the
additional services, which
is called the Tech
Entrepreneur Nanodegree,
but right beside it,
you'll be able to sign up
for all of the courses
that I just mentioned
and take all of the
content for free.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: So you're
here today at Founder World.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: What is it that
you're trying to accomplish?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
Well, we really
want to empower entrepreneurs
to be able to not only tell them
about this amazing content, but
then they can ask me questions.
They can ask my partner
Clark about questions,
who's from Udacity as well.
And people are just
here experiencing,
meeting other people,
networking, getting
encouragement, learning what's
working for other platforms.
And that's really what you
need as an entrepreneur.
You need a lot of support,
because it definitely
gets tough along the way.
So just being able to support
people and answer the burning
questions that they may have
has been really valuable.
Everyone's been really,
really responsive.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's really cool.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: Thank you
so much for joining me.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Of course.
KORY JEFFREY: Thank you
guys for joining me on-site
at Founder World
in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]